it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the wrong
gene Cronus code from the CBS television
news staff Larry Mercer and Charles
Collingwood our distinguished guest for
this evening is the honorable Alfred a
cedarburg United States representative
from Michigan well the opening shots
have already been fired in the coming
congressional elections and from now on
until November there won't be a dull
moment in politics the most evenly
divided Congress since world war one is
straining at the leash to get back home
to campaign but they've got a lot of
work to do and only one month to do it
in our representative cedarburg you're a
member of the House Appropriations
Committee and the most important thing
for the federal government as well as
for everyone else is money now have you
finished your vast appropriation bills
for the fiscal year well Larry
practically finished let's put it that
way I believe that as far as the house
of representatives are concerned we are
just about finished with the
appropriation bills however we do have
one of the major bills pending before us
the present time and that's the foreign
aid bill which of course is very often
one of the most controversial bills that
we have on the floor then we do have
some other bills the military
construction bill which is before the
subcommittee of which I am a member that
bill will be brought up as I understand
in a deficiency appropriation and will
probably be taken care of in a matter of
the possibly the next ten days now how
are you going to vote on that foreign
aid bill I ask you represent a soon
Larry that you would probably ask me
that question as I feel right at the
present time I am inclined to vote
against the appropriation for foreign
aid however I will say that the bill is
much more palatable this year than it
has
then in the past because the present
administration has done a terrific job
in getting it down to shall we say
common sense levels approximately three
and a half billion dollars this year
much of which or shall we say most of
which is for a military rather than
economic aid congressman cedarburg you
said you were going to vote against the
foreign aid bill you've been in its
present form would you be disposed to
vote for it if it were less or alter
generally I think I might go along with
it if it were substantially reduced and
I say that for this reason you know we
have a large unobligated balance in the
foreign aid fund some of the fund of
course is obligated but there's a great
deal of it that has not been as yet
obligated I'm told from the debate that
took place this afternoon that
approximately sufficient funds are left
in the foreign aid bill for nate account
so that we could run the program at its
present level for almost two more fiscal
years now I realize that you can't call
a project or a program this large
finished at a given time and that has to
be stretched out over a period of time
but I think they've just got a little
bit too much money to play with and I'd
like to take a little bit away from
Cassandra excuse me Charlie I was just
going to say speaking in foreign aid
Harold Stassen was supposed to be up
here tonight but he was kept down and
washing by the Churchill meeting now
like to ask you this question you think
this meeting between President
Eisenhower and Sir Winston Churchill is
really going to do any good well let's
say that we hope it will do some good ah
I feel this way about that particular
meeting that it's always a good idea for
two states to get together and have a
good friendly discussion once in a while
because we have some very honest
differences of opinion it appears and I
hope something will good good will come
from it well I think it's possible for
two great allies to have honest
differences of opinion it's just like a
we shall we say our wives we don't
always agree with our lives
times but that doesn't mean we're going
to take a walk that means that we're
going to sit down and probably iron out
our differences and I hope that's what
we're doing here but you do feel that it
spite of the way you feel about the
president for an ID bill that we need
allies like Great Britain well equipped
to stand by us in cases then a nice
currently believe that we need allies
but I'm not convinced that we can
necessarily by allies with american
dollars I think we've got to have a good
sound faith in one another as allies
they must believe in us we must believe
in them we must have some common goals
and it seems to me that the common goal
here is to definitely show the rest of
the world that the American and the way
of life that we allies are interested in
is best for the entire peoples of this
name of this representative cedarburg
some of the members of your party like
Secretary of State Dulles have
complained that you people on the
appropriations committees are penny
pinchers and we particularly call
attention to the fact that you cut back
his State Department twenty percent
while Russia is pouring vast sums and
making considerable progress in the Cold
War how about it Larry in your long
experience as a news analyst and so
forth have you ever recall the time when
any member of the executive branch has
said that the Appropriations Committee
ever gave him too much money or that
possibly they even give them just enough
well let's say Truman objected didn't
lead to the amount of money which was
once appropriated for the Air Force and
they kept some of it in escrow as if
we're at ur effect I think maybe I
believe he is the one who vetoed the 70
wing Air Force wasn't he hmm that's
right and you know why suppose we could
get a little pinochle about the city of
Eric how about those cuts in student
exchange from not from 15 minute a nine
million dollars now is that economy or
is that dice elation i'll give you my
own personal opinion I don't think its
economy I think that there is a field
which we an American can well support
because I believe that the bringing of
exchange students here giving them a
glimpse of what we have here in
America by comparison to what we have in
other nations not in a braggadocio way
but to show them what free people can do
I think is important and you know we are
in real competition with our Russian
shall we say friends that i hope we can
count them as friends sometime but they
are bringing forth as I understand great
programs and bringing students from some
of these other nations into Russia and I
think we have to combat not that and I
think it's a good program yes but why
was it cut back then well probably in
half probably i'll tell you why probably
because the subcommittee that handles
that in the appropriations committee
felt that they could do the job with a
lesser amount of money and possibly
they're wrong if so the Senate has a
great ability of adding to what the
house takes out so possibly something
will be done along that line represent a
city break what about the labor and
health department now you cut back mrs.
hobbies Department about 15 million
dollars and some people say our health
program is a stretcher case now well I'm
not convinced that our health program is
a stretcher case at all I think that
we're going forward and making great
strides and if you'll compare what we
have done in the years past with what
we're doing at the present time
appropriation wise you'll find that we
haven't done too badly and I'll say this
that as far as I'm personally concerned
I think the federal government would do
well if they would do what they could to
be sure that the states in the local
communities are adequately aware of the
of the problem themselves you know one
of the easiest things in the world to do
is to when you get into a little problem
locally and I've had a little experience
with that as a mayor of a well shall we
say a town of around 55,000 people that
you have the opportunity to turn to
Uncle Sam you're going to take it every
time well let me turn to another case
though there's a Labor Department now
you've made deep slashes and that almost
a million dollars and Labor Department
people complain that they haven't got
enough inspectors to go around and
oversee the keeping of the minimum wage
laws and that surely is a federal job
day job well Larry actually I would
hesitate to say too much about that
because I am NOT thoroughly familiar
with it however I will say this that I'm
positive if we are not adequately
enforcing the minimum wage laws who a
lack of appropriation that the present
administration will make mighty sure
that we have a supplemental
appropriation when we come back next
January to see that the jobs properly
done you know I think one of the great
things that we can do in these
appropriation matters I as this that if
you find that you're running a little
short at the end of the year you can
always come back for more and if they
prove their case before the
Appropriations Committee we're not so
bad that we won't give it to them if
they have a good case you mean that
appropriations have nothing to do with
expenditures and well appropriations do
have something to do with expenditures
however you do of course always have the
problem of the carryovers for instance
as we before we went into Korea and as
the korean incident developed we found
ourselves with appropriations which were
rather huge because we had a crash
program we knew not what korea meant in
reality it may have well taken us into
the third world war and I'm not
criticizing anybody for that but we have
had tremendous backlog of unexpended
appropriations for instance in fiscal
year 53 we had 78 and 7 tenths billion
dollars we got that down in fiscal year
54 266 and a half billion die for you
getting all these deep figures the
representative cedarburg is our uri your
economizing of this year is that going
to be enough to keep us from raising the
national debt limit well I can only say
that having talked to Secretary of
Treasury Humphrey and actually having
her team just on television yesterday he
anticipates that it's still going to be
necessary you probably realize that we
in the house took care of that matter
last year and it's up for the Senate to
decide now what they want to do
personally I'm much more concerned about
the people who are many
our national debt those who are
responsible for seeing that we spend our
money wisely and that we are getting a
dollar value for every dollar spent as
much as close as we can in governments a
good idea will generate a very action do
you think that the people are going to
give President Eisenhower a Republican
administration well I'm sure ogress to
work with Larry I sure think so because
I don't see why they wouldn't you know
this administration reduced taxes seven
and a half billion dollars that's the
first time taxes have been reduced in
many many years and our democratic
friends never reduced anybody's taxes
and in addition to that we've increased
social security we'd like to do it more
and we've got we've a large road program
the st. Lawrence Seaway many things I'm
enthused about that nice ready to sing
campaign talkin some information in I'd
represent easy to work the opinions
expressed on the lawn team Chronos cope
or those of the speakers the editorial
board for this edition of the lawn gene
krona scope was Larry lesser and Charles
Collingwood our distinguished guest was
the Honorable elfrid a cedarburg United
States representative from Michigan